mind blown it's like a world domination
of talent the whole world is here right
now
and it's the best of the best I actually
have a bad feeling about this
it's a pleasure to be back it's
extremely surreal since it's been seven
years since my initial appearance on the
show and there's hardly been a whirlwind
of a week prepping for this this wife
Caroline is now handing him bobby pins
in order to pick the locks Oh No the
performance is going to be an escape
that is kind of a step up from an escape
that almost killed me a few years ago
when I was out touring I am always aware
of the danger with the escapes that I
perform but when something actually goes
wrong it definitely snaps me into that
reality a bit more than normally would
it's fun to be on TV I hear the camera
adds ten fingers third was great but I
want to be a champion I want to win so
I'm very excited to be back I'm coming
in all guns blazing ready to go it's
gonna be one of my best looking
performances of all time the judge I
would say I'm probably trying to really
impress would be Heidi I want to win her
over obviously I want to win everybody
over but like Heidi I know is a
particularly tough cookie when it comes
to the comedian's
so my goal is to impress her as much as
I can
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so honored to be back and I can't
wait to perform bumper for me ashes by
Celine Dion
[Music]
I'm really excited I would probably
collab with ariana grande because she's
just my inspiration it seems like second
grade
[Music]
there's absolutely incredible to win
Bryn's Got Talent but to be able to come
out here and prove that we were
champions out here as well that would be
just amazing the icing on the cake
it's been an honor sharing X with you I
am X thank you yes
X is back you're gonna see excellent
you're only gonna see me kind of
introduce X and then the rest is all X I
am super excited to be on this platform
on this scale is the next level
[Music]